it was just like whoa this random [ __ ]
that I just made like if I was in a club
I heard this beat I'll be singing this
to myself and I was like oh that's like
the first song I ever named after the
hook I never named a song like after the
lyrics cuz I thought that's stupid
I just never know what I'm talking about
until it's over it's like how can I know
my song before it's over and then I
guess I'd rather name it about what I'm
talking about rather than just like
what's the coulomb and for this song I
like what did I find a hook again I
don't know this time it just felt like
I'm gonna do it was a short song - it
was like short and sweet one take
supermodel well my friend I like just
taught himself how to play the guitar
like a day before then so he just
repeated those chords like the same two
or three chords over and over again and
then they were just really sad I didn't
go to do that song to work on that
I just did the other things and at the
end the day I'm like I'm on a good mood
like what's that thing like play those
chords that you're playing earlier so I
just kind of responded to the
information in like natural way and
that's just what came out wasn't no
engineer to me was Ray Charles Brown I
really really liked him he was wonderful
I loved his name - it was so dramatic I
was like damn I felt comfortable with
him I trusted everything about the
situation like it was just like a safe
place - it was just like whoa this
random [ __ ] that I just made like if I
was in a club I heard this be I'll be
saying this to myself I was just writing
about this particular boy I really liked
him he was lucky like trash to me but I
really liked his like validation but you
also suck it just takes me through all
our shenanigans but it's the silliest
Ranger
it was fun I come from a freestyle space
and they have to be like to write
something on paper I have ADHD I just
want to be kind of did it it in like I
was like okay but this is just like the
demo right and then we're gonna like get
a real B and then did it throw me some
fire ass James I'm running to him and I
was just like I wanna play you something
[Music]
great this could be on the radio doesn't
Charles on it then he put James on it
fast it was amazing for other two
different drum patterns they were both
flies they were like okay let's try like
one in the friends away one second
friends let's try the first verse for
all the verses it was so hard to put a
minute timing trippy then you go back
and forth during mixes and be like you
want the book was a friend when I'm a
bag you want a reverb no you when I'm
dry as hell okay well let's try to nudge
everything 20 samples to the right and
then put the jump every niche I felt
like we were getting like farther away
but let close there maybe you listen
again maybe like I don't know what the
[ __ ] is gonna I just put it back the way
we tried all that and just didn't I work
out it turned out sticks he had a job
he with a studio he just casually were
just like yeah just in terms of a he
just went in there and just five died
and those are the jobs I love this job
the frills are synthetic Stix was
playing live so it was just a matter of
like textures and timing and that
natural human swing like sticks was just
in that natural human in person swing
that's like an acoustic vibe that's an
in-person vibe and then like I'm it's a
one take on my hands so it's like it's
all of us like kind of just doing that
once I got a sign a teeny yes stop
recording like in a space that I was
comfortable in it was just more like
this is a studio
welcome to the studio who had tried to
just kind of like work through it but I
just wasn't comfortable I prefer like if
I could build a little studio like in a
house that I'm staying I just worked
better and like a house it was like okay
breakfast I had my choice I'm real good
comfort and confidence is so key like it
really is like some artists can be
comfortable anywhere because they're
very like cerebral I'm a visual person
I'm very reactive to my environment wood
and stone in the middle of the woods
also and it's perfect it was like the
ingredients for stuff to happen and we
also made chicken when it came time to
make a batch of songs in my head like
what's good enough in the automobile
eggs was pretty I was like this isn't
okay like this should be at the end that
was the one time I've ever been right I
knew what that song was different and I
just didn't know why but I knew that it
was different from anything I've ever
done it's very almost afraid of who
descended to because it was so different
and then once I sent it to like the
meanest person I didn't and they were
like the oldest she was already know
like I was like let me show the people I
wrote all of my own music just never
thought I'd have anything on the radio
but I thought that to be on the radio
you need somebody to help you write
because that's what happens I'm just
thankful honestly they're like God made
my way it's good enough to like reach
other people and connect and like grow
on their own I perform it differently
than I recorded it but I still
I recorded it and that's rare I don't
know what um timing I was on that was
weird I just I can't get back into the
time he gave me so strange it's my
favorite song on my album it was really
honest and I guess I wasn't thinking
about it so it was like a real piece of
my subconscious that like I liked the
way it was like I didn't feel like why
was I thinking that or like what
whatever like it's a throwaway or just
like whatever thought I was just like no
I believe in every like weird thought it
makes sense to me
[Music]